steve forbes chairman and
editor-in-chief of forbes media and
former presidential candidate is in
focus now steve this feels like we are
running around in circles what is the
president trying to do
the president's trying to have it always
uh this whole thing on vaccines is very
confusing uh people don't like the
coercion part of it and it is leading to
uh people getting fired here we have
health workers being laid off at a time
when there's a shortage of them airlines
same thing and so uh the delta variant
that hurt in september and this vaccine
mandate's also going to hurt what comes
out of this jobs report is what's
amazing is how the economy is just
raring to go if these artificial
barriers are removed
if you look at the household survey
which better hits small businesses
hitting what small businesses are doing
the job creation was actually 526 000.
the big decline in jobs came not in the
private sector which was up over 300 000
september revised another up 100 000 for
july and august the big fall off was in
government workers that is especially in
the schools with these crazy mandates
people confused about what they can and
cannot do so these are
government-inflicted uh
government-inflicted report not
something about the natural health of
the economy which would heal quickly if
certain things were not stupidly done be
blunt about it
that that is so fascinating so what
you're saying is that president biden
effectively is getting his own workforce
fired i mean those are the people that
he can control
in the government right
that's mind-boggling huge companies like
ibm and american airlines are now
already warning their employees that if
they are not vaccinated by november 24th
that's their deadline
they will be fired
ibm they don't even take into account
people who've had the disease where the
immunity is better than the vaccines
this kind of one-size-fits-all
blunderbuss from the top very
destructive ultimately
so steve i just looked it up ibm is the
seventh largest company in the in the
nation i mean they hire a whole lot of
folk and we know that that small
businesses hire upwards of 66 of the
american workforce and they're hurt by
this because they have to hire literally
their own vaccines are to figure out
who's vaccinated and who's not for their
customer base like in new york and also
their employees what is this going to do
to the price of things
well what it does is artificially raise
costs
we have a cost rising because the fed is
printing too much money which will
avalanche the economy next year when
they stop the gimmicks from preventing
it this year which they'll run out of
and uh but uh they just artificially
they what the the whole thing the
breakdown of the supply chain from
covert one economists and experts
underestimated grossly what happens when
you shut down the whole global economy
you don't turn it on like a light switch
or a faucet so that takes time but then
they keep adding these artificial
barriers which stand in the way raise
costs and that's going to hit the
consumer which will hit the economy
connect the dots hello
i know it seems so basic and of course
you're so great at explaining things it
just kind of makes you even understand
it to the point like you want to call
the white house and say what don't you
get but we can't do that anyway
meanwhile democrats
and the fbi yeah we could try
but only because we're parents um
democrats are no closer to a deal on the
spending bill
and and you know biden is his whole
agenda in peril now progressives saying
that they are willing to negotiate but
they want a higher price tag than some
moderates i mean a lot higher and one of
the holdouts is arizona senator kirsten
cinema we've seen her harassed all over
the place the bathroom the plane it
happened again
congresswoman senator
senator cinema would you please tell
um
the majority of
americans who support buildback better
why you won't vote for it
who are you going to leave behind
seniors who need health care folks who
need housing the climate crisis who are
you going to leave behind senator
she did correct her title she's earned
it she's a senator steve
yes
she is a senator and so far a very
courageous one under intense pressure
which she and the senator mentioned
recognized it's not just the top line
number as we know we can manipulate that
you can take in 10 years of estimated
tax revenues and only have five years of
spending everything will expire in three
to five years so what's your problem uh
people are on to that game also they're
going to try to fob off costs on paper
to the states to make that number look
even lower the key thing is what you're
putting into that bill massive new
entitlements which you never get rid of
which will undermine various parts of
the american economy and leave behind
millions of people as lincoln put it who
want to improve their lot in life
because there'll be less opportunity so
this bill is going to harm
the fundamentally change the american
whole economic system and social system
and there's very little debate on it you
want free community college ask why are
college costs going up so much higher
than the rate of inflation because of
administrative bloat
why don't they address that these are
all issues that deserve debate and
discussion instead of trying to ram it
through on one grand bill that
fundamentally turns america upside down
and we're not supposed to say anything
about it and the police powers for the
irs very very ominous everything you do
is now going to be in the purview
absolutely irish agents
no it's true it's and and i said this
week i mean if they sick the if the doj
sticks the fbi on parents
i mean that's that's two lanes of
intimidation that you have for most
americans the irs and now potentially
the fbi's new focus on parents you said
something that was so true and so
jarring i want to make sure people get
it on our way out steve and and that is
that entitlements rolled into a huge
bill like this you never get rid of them
because no matter what you do you don't
line redline them in an executive order
like nobody goes if they're even reading
them the first time these bills nobody
goes back through and says you know what
on page
2550 let's redline that one entitlement
you are so right about that they become
permanent steve forbes thank you for
being in focus today thank you